Remember, our goal in analyzing this Facebook user data is to
understand our users and their behavior. This question is just another
dimension where we're trying to understand which segment of our population
uses a certain feature on the website. In this case, we're
wondering whether or not males or females end up using likes
on the World Wide Web more often. So, first I'm just
going to remind myself of what variables are in my data set.
I'm wanting to compare likes between the genders, so I'm going to
use www_likes. This code would give me a histogram which isn't
what I want. And remember I also need to subset my
data to remove any values for gender that are NA.
Now this bit of code is starting to look more like what
I want. But, I've only got one frequency polygon on here,
and I need two. So I'm going to use the color
parameter, and pass a gender. That seems a little bit better.
I'm also going to add scale x continuous, since I know that
World Wide Web likes is on a continuous scale. Alright, now
we're looking at a reasonable plot. Zooming in, it looks like males
typically have more likes on the web. But I can't really make
sense of the tail end of this graph. This is long tail
data, so let's use a log transformation to see if we can
get a better look at what's happening down here. I'm going to
go back to my code and add a scale x log 10.
Running this code we get a different plot with much more information.
It looks like males have more likes on the web
at first, but we can see that females overtake males
at this point in the graph. So this still leaves
me wondering who really has more likes, men or women?